from Snoop's manager stood there
then stood there and I knew what it looked like it was
from Koran hatchang and he
took this camera from me said why are you
filming and I said I'm
from DAB CNN is a West Coast Rap
site well I  said that I
wanted to interview Superfly Superfly is
the manager was completely confused was
of course everyone is there to talk to Noob
or something and then said you wanted to
interview Superfly I said yes he
said okay come here after the concert
and then we can do the
concert went there  had
returned my camera while we
were somehow walking around the room and
interviewing Superfly. Otherwise, I
ran into Noob in the hallway
and I just called what do
you mean by Snoop on the
phone and said
[music]
welcome  on the OMR podcast
today, absolute German hidden
champion from the music business,
but not so much from
German but from American, there's
a pretty incredible
story and it's from no one
that I've honestly known for a long time
because we studied at the same university,
but I didn't have one  Really plan what
became of him because he
went to the USA straight after his studies here in Hamburg. Now
we have a warm welcome here in Hamburg again, dear
hi, thank you very much, hi How
are you, you're actually a
native of Hamburg, I'm 11
Moved here from Iran a few months ago,
so I was born in Iran, but
I have my first memories in Hamburg, okay,
then here, let's say, I
grew up very, very down-to-earth, I think my
parents weren't
particularly well equipped, anyway,
from Iran to Hamburg during the Iran-Iraq War
first came as an
asylum seeker, my father had two
sisters here, which made it a bit
easier and then, um, yes, my father was an
architect in Iran but his
degree was invalid here, so he had
done construction work in restaurants through friends, better
then I think  I know I was three and four years
old, opened his first restaurant
in Bergedorf and then
my mother studied German
and my mother spoke
French,
went to French school in Iran and then
at some point started
giving French lessons here and
has been doing so for years  the Turkish
community of Hamburg and works on
integration courses for refugee
parents and stories like that and you
have now studied business administration
and media science here, so
I went to the French
school here in Hamburg, this Francine
dombuch, I was in kindergarten until I graduated from
high school
but after that,
strangely enough, which means strangely enough,
I had a very bad Abitur
degree, had 3.8 NC even though
I skipped the third grade,
but things weren't going so well towards the Abitur,
but I wanted to do things I did
very early on when I was at French
school  There were 12 school comments I
skipped a grade I wanted to go
into debt when I was just before six years old
I finished high school at the end of 16
and actually wanted to go straight to
America My mother said under
no circumstances do you have to study
anything here study anything the only place I can  When I
came in here at the University of Hamburg, I was studying
French literature, so
I did my bachelor's degree in French
and American
literature, but
then I found the Medias
School Hamburg Media School where there were
nbas and I had
already asked if I could go with them
The literary studies also
came in and they said that wasn't a
problem and then um yes then I did it
because we were cool in the medias
um in any case you then went
straight to the USA or what felt like in your head you were
already in the USA because if you  So about you,
you've always done an online portal,
there was CNN and
it was about West Coast Hip Hop
and you wrote it yourself. Like many others, I was
pretty obsessed with rap in the 90s, for many
it was a phase  some but
at some point I switched to something else.
I got into it very deeply when
the Internet became so big and I
found people in the world on Internet forums and some message boards before the social media age who
somehow had the same interests  like
me and um I've always had an interest
in writing, I think I've been
relatively gifted linguistically so that since I was
at home with Persian with my
father French and my mother because
she was only in French school and then
German outside and English camera
relatively quickly and  I
just started writing a lot in English
and I
think we started this website in 2002 and
just
wrote about rap music and started
interviewing some underground artists who contacted us and I
think that makes it
easy to make these contacts  I continued to maintain
it, it continued to develop,
I think I had quite a bit of tunnel
vision at some point and all
other hobbies
fell away no after another, from football to
tennis to video games and everything else
slowly fell away and how
long or how big was the portal  then as, so
to speak,
30 30 40,000 unique users per day in
2005 67 but only from Germany
less so Germany of course too but
it was a lot too America and um that
was always like this for me this this
this paradoxical because I
lived here and here almost entirely  I
was a normal student in America and
California and I had already built up a name for myself
then when I
flew to everyone for the first time at 16 after graduating from high school, I
realized that I
actually had a name and someone was
in that scene, which was completely
confusing at first  But it
was clear to me that it was okay, I want to
go there at some point, so that means they
just have, hey, you're the type of person who's allowed here,
no, I mean, I've been
writing about it for years and I
've already done interviews with, I
mean, I have  50 Cent Interview that he
shot the video in the club over the
phone when I was somehow still 14 14
years old before I turned 15
with my voice still breaking and so I think that's
because I was so young and that
was the Internet was different back then
Because before social media I think the
internet was freer in the sense that you did
n't have a social profile with a picture and
stuff like that, you were just
a user and you were worth as much
as what you said, nobody
knew how old you were or what you looked like
where you live back
then people didn't
necessarily know who it was because he was
writing that and now
doing an interview so there weren't these
Googles yet, someone just sees everything that's
supposed to because your articles that
are there mostly interviews
went well or  what
song reviews or I did hours of
interviews and then typed them all
up that was all about I
was with my mother in my bedroom at the time
but my mother was at
home
that the house phone was on loudspeaker and I
had your coffee cash register
and my coffee cup had the computer microphone
in it  Coffee cup in like that over the
house phone and then recorded on a computer
and somehow did
a two hour interview with
my favorite artist at the time from
Snoop Dogg to Cypress Hill to who knows
who and then you
typed it up and published it and we
know  When I arrived,
it was all, um, let's say step by step. I
mean, um, I usually first
established contact with the DJ through some email or
some people in the crew. I
think I was so interested in the culture
that I wasn't even interested in it at first
somehow interviewing the big stars,
it all
developed very organically over time and
you can do that, it became big
simply because it was recommended to others
like world of wars or about SEO or or
I have everything, that was everything, so we
have everything
somehow  Made out of instinct somewhere,
I remember the first time
when someone didn't contact me
and wanted to put up banner advertising.
I didn't know how much I should
pay
for it
month and if he said yes right away
I knew okay, I could
probably have said a little more, yes,
said no at first, yes, take
me into it.
In 2017, I was maybe 19 and we had
already built up a very good relationship with Snoop, um and he has an
album  released so at the label
he said he wanted to do it with us and
he won or one of the
majors wrote to me at the time and
said yes we want to do takeover for three months,
how much does
it cost and I remember that I have
with mine  Friends in my parents
talked into something like that, what do I say then
how much does it cost now and I
think I said 20,000 dollars
but said we only have a
budget of 11,000, some okay then we'll do
11,000 but that's how I got the
medias school back then and many  Other things are
just paid for, I've never worked, I
'm wrong about banner advertising and
stuff like that, when you're
programming, no, it was a friend from
England programming, I can
have very basic Edge because I had
time to come where that was before
WordPress  and some stories
you had to know basic programming, I mean if
you did MySpace back then
you also had to know basic programming,
but friends had done that in England but then
you're
here after you graduate and then you
finally moved to
the USA  about what from there so then then the
first step so that how did you
use your fame or yours so to speak and it is to be built up that we
today that so I
always knew I wanted to
end up somewhere music business
I didn't know exactly where I was I was never
um  Driven by money or motivated by
money, my goal back then was always to
hopefully earn enough money with something that I
liked so that I
could lead a decent life. I did
n't have any grandiose dreams when it came to that.
I think I'm relatively
down-to-earth. I grew up in Hamburg
and this idea of ​​the American dream
or something like that wasn't
really what motivated me but rather to
do something that I like and to be
able to make a living from it and I knew
relatively early on that everything has to be that
it won't be so you can
write it like that  a lot you want so that will
have a seal somewhere so
then of course okay the website
got big and why don't you sell it
and but I was too proud
somehow I once that my baby I did
n't want to sell it on to
anyone
I know at the time  medias was cool in
Hamburg Media School, um
interestingly enough,
the only medium that
was left out was music.
Unfortunately, we still overprinted and
talked about film and things like that online, but it
was just at the time in 2009
89 when the music industry was completely gone  in a state of
upheaval,
streaming had not yet arrived in Germany,
the download model did
n't really work in Germany anyway,
they still had half of CDs
and that was just the way it was at the time when
I can understand what they mean, okay, how
should we  Now I'm teaching someone,
but it was already clear to me back then
that that's what I wanted to do and
we allowed them
to write my master's theses about everything
that interested me, so
the media was somehow cool for me. I
always say I have a lot  learned in the
sense of teamwork and such organization
and such stories but what was
taught was not necessarily something
that was of direct interest to me but
for the fault for the internship during
the medias school had skip
me and my contact at One a l.a
clarified on the internship and a few  Months before the
internship was supposed to be because I was on the
phone with
rapper with whom we worked a lot
on the website
Snoop Dogg's Crew, his cousin who
made a lot of music with him and he
just told me about Gazi Gazi Shami and
said that he was in the  Barry and San
Francisco
does digital sales stories and
works with a lot of artists that
I deal with and that I
should connect with them because this is someone
with whom he thinks I
would get along well, so we
gave him his number back then  contacted him he knew
may you remember and my
website he used to
produce music for his applicants and um
I mean pretty much
do an internship you need this
school credits and he said yes you are
welcome to come he worked for Ingrid at the time,
another digital
music distributor who later from  Universal
was bought then San Francisco
said you can spend the summers
I'll give you the school credits and I
said okay it felt better than
going to one I was my fan of being
a big part of something small
than being a small part of  something big,
okay, you're going to say how typical
interns do things here, that
sounds interesting. In the worst case scenario,
I'm spending the summer in San
Francisco and was always an Ella
and had never been to San Francisco
when he flew there for
the summer together  spent together
relatively quickly realized that we
think very similarly he was maybe 12
years older than me and very well
around it what his background was
he
used to work in the first.com boom in Silicon
Valley at
various streaming companies and at
San Micro  System
but at the same time I used to rap and
produce, I'm an audio engineer and
generally just a very, very
informed
person and I
became a mentor relatively quickly, someone I
could look out for and then when I
went back after the summer and
thought I was doing my final year  He said
that when I finished university
he would probably have started something new. He didn't have a name at the time
but he needed help. He did
n't have a salary or anything for me yet but if
I was interested then
I should stay in touch
Then I went back to Hamburg and
did the last university
and then went back the next summer
and wrote my master's thesis in San
Francisco. He got the
first office and had the first
administrative person who helped him,
but there were three of them  in this office and there
he has the name Empire um basically
today a label is a distributor or
what is a label a distributor a
publisher
everything everything under one under one house
with the focus on about music no
not at all complete all all all
all genre  Hip hop is what we
started with but now we
are the biggest
but Nigerian music a lot of
South Africa we have an office in London we
have a lot of Asian music we have
so we are almost on site now from
back then the two of you put it on
now you are  involved in the company
so Empire and is now the
company you're talking about what's
behind how many people
want to work about 200 people there are
about 100 of us in San Francisco there is the
headquarters there are always surprised
why is San Francisco why  not
she was born in San
Francisco and has seen his whole life
how his girlfriend or other
creatives had to leave home and get a
foothold in the music industry and
he wanted to build something
at home and San Francisco is also the
one for technology and  Innovation and that's why
we're just, I think,
structured a little differently, think a
little differently, were always something we are
we are qu we
started in the time of change in the
music industry and believe without
realizing it at the time contributed to
the music industry, especially in the
States to move to what
they are now have,
I think, shown other different values ​​than what you
typically see in the music industry
from the investors now
independent no investors completely
independent of you both,
the company belongs to him I am  I have
a stake okay but I mean
or or are there other
employees colleagues who also hold a few
hands
okay okay um what do we do with the
label
I want to you again is not public
so but it's somehow 100
million or something like that or
much more  than that really that
's gigantic for a company with
only 200 people so only but we are
the largest independent
music label in the USA which is not
one of the lean bound is awesome and let's say
a few big names are
also represented so I mean  so the
names you know here of course we
have a lot with so Snoop
Dogan Park's first half Kendrick Lamar
started with us we
made his first two albums that was my
first drawing with a few back then um
for the younger generation
xxx tentaciones one of the  most
streamed artist of the last
decade, who unfortunately passed away a few years ago,
was
with us his entire career but we don't
have a lot of electronic music in the scene.
Music]
we are the same age, I
did my first interview when he was 16.
I was 16 when I was first an Ali
and I heard a mixtape back then.
You can still watch it on YouTube today
and I had a
relationship with him back then  in his label and when
he released his first mixtape and
changed his name from colder to Kendrick
Lamar as Kendrick normal, they contacted us and
we distributed it at the time  Over
the
years it has developed into a complete label
label but we have
released its first two old ones and
deducted them so that they have all fallen down and have been discontinued
since 2012.
Assuming the site is still there, there
are still people who post things
but I'm laid
because Empire even has you there now
In 2011 we had our
tenth anniversary for dub CNN in 2012
and shortly after that I decided I
can't be a label boss who
does interviews at the same time so that
finding the right people early or
being early I think our deals
were um by a lot um  fairer than what has
traditionally been seen, we were,
we placed a lot of emphasis on transparency,
making everything education deals, the
artist also understands what he is
signing and water that we don't
do, um, the artists in situations where they
then later
somehow badmouth their label about their lives
Because I've been interviewing artists for ten years, it's
very rare that
you find artists who talk well about their
label. Most of the time there's always something
wrong here, something isn't right at all
and I
think we both
came from a perspective where we valued it very much  We
focused on
having good relationships with the artists
we work with,
I think we approached the whole thing differently,
okay,
and
why did you never think together about
actually changing,
taking investors in, and that kind of thing was never an
issue or is it  To date, no topic
has wanted to go with the thing,
so I don't want to bring in investors, I
think they probably say it's
sales, it's the wind in our
sails, it's what allows us to
do what we want. At the end
of the year, we don't have to explain to anyone why we
what we did was basically and
I think his things from where we
both connected it means we were
n't both on a
lot of money at once. It was
once much more interesting for us
to just do our own thing, which
might take a long time, but  In
the end, it's more sustainable if you
now lose in a candle like that,
so it was shown earlier and
then it's gone anyway, so it's
not like that again and again. It
took years until we slowly got to this point,
brick by brick, step by step
and could ensure that we did
n't lose artists, that there was
always
a
ceiling for a pendance that was either
somehow getting on the radio or
international marketing or
having the big budgets, there was always a
limit and for us that was less
interesting to say  Here let someone
bring in so that we don't have this with the limit
but how do we do it
ourselves the name Empire
it's always about fishing your self,
not being dependent on
anyone else we have
always taken the longer route which is then
ours  own was and um is mostly
in the music industry there are many
independent labels that have risen
like a success and then
someone comes along offers enough money and buys it
up and then at some point it
burns and then the part becomes
ludolstadt and I have no idea
more to the his label that
originally started and for us
especially for horny no matter she was
born more than it is Palestinian it
has always been by nature someone who did
n't have no officially recognized
identity can the who
shouldn't actually exist in
this industry and uh building something
that you then hand over to someone else
was something that could be asked for by them
and I think
I shared this mentality somewhere, I
was never interested in it, I personally
never dreamed that you
would one day be as big as I am  I would have been
happy with something small
that I can live on but no matter,
I think she was a visionary who
saw a few steps ahead and
developed it further. If we meet in five
years there will be 1000 people and
so I think so because I mean we are
ours  big focus as I said, we
started with rap music. Rap ​​music
was our
passion, it's what we both
grew up with, I think,
but now I think the
time of global dominance of American
music is over and it will continue year after
year
crumble and music becomes regional music
is getting bigger and bigger that you can see with the
rise of Latino music that someone
with the rise of African music
the industries and that didn't exist
in different countries and
regions that are slowly being built up
and um those that
hear today are more easy  global music
and this this this idea that
American music dominates the whole world,
this will
gradually become less and less and I
think we started as a kurbild with a
very strong focus on
international and started to have
territory managers in different
countries  we opened an office in London we
want South Africa in
Nigeria we have people we now have
someone in Germany France
Holland Spain Egypt Indonesia Germany
difficult so Gasi always wanted
me to do more in Germany because
I'm from here and therefore
I always spoke German  a little more
cautious about what was going on,
maybe because for me the German
market is always a very mature
market, it's a very saturated one,
it's difficult to be the first
to do something in Germany, and I think that was one of the reasons
why I wanted to leave here
in Germany says now give me
ten reasons why something doesn't
work before you focus on the two
reasons why it
could work. It was always difficult for me
the Germans wait until everyone else
has tried everything and then
you come and do it better than everyone
else
Of
course, it didn't always generalize that way, but
when we started and I
told people here in Germany what
we had done, but very music
sales, the thinking is there's
just why why what what do you
eat something else if you try
to tell people but our culture
is different the relationship and this and
that and it was somehow
getting back into the strap business it was
always um for me because I was a little more
careful I was more my for
you I
grew up in Hamburg like that  so Samy Deluxe his
meant deluxe
definitely so that was definitely
my
thing next to me on the
American stuff and um I
helped people on the side I
did a few things with the 187 guys when
they were over there or this
At that time I also made a prediction with his
what did you think video that went through the
roof in America and, um,
little things like that, but really being in
Germany as a German artist
and what to start, I haven't started yet,
I've been toying with the idea,
I have a lot  good friend
Patrick Schaffler, DJ static here from
Hamburg, his label is called Females
and he's been trying to convince me for years to
do more here,
okay, um,
but
I think
now I'm more open to it
a little more to present because
I also noticed that I
did an interview from 3 years ago with Hip hop.de
with Aria and Rusty who flew to LA
because they interviewed us with Snoop
Dogg.de and what they
did with Tiger  us was scanned
and um they interviewed me back then
and
I think the interview had over 100,000 clicks
on YouTube and to this day I still get
messages from people from German
from kids from producers from fans who
say how inspired they are by this
story because  It's for them in its
own strange unique stories, um
this is a boy from Hamburg, um
somehow a fan of his in
a business like this, so people have been
writing for years now and again people say hey,
look here is a video of Nima, he's
running here with Snoop somehow  through
any videos or are you
actually watching videos um you have to
say how the stars came and then um
Super Bowl last year there was a
l.a. I saw this
amazing half time show at the stadium and yes you were
you were at the start but you  You were also
all of these artists in one loose
and so far, so to speak, super close to
this big one,
but I think also, um, various
others, so tell me a little about
the perhaps most interesting ones, it's
always I was always the one in Hamburg,
unfortunately she was the only one  what people
knew is the boy who is Snoop's
friend
he wrote my letters of recommendation
for my green card so that
I could get my cell phone
so that I could get my green card so
I got my recommendation from okay so
yeah yeah my dad did blonde with hookers
but
not the first  The time I played a
concert here in Cologne in 2005, I was 17 or 18
and I was in contact with his
DJ who had organized tickets for me
because I had interviewed a DJ and I
was at this concert at the time. They had
camcorders with them and that was the case
Time as I said before
imagine because of course you have your cell phone in
the air at that time it was at the
concert you didn't film it I
had my camera and filmed from above
and then suddenly
security came and wanted to take the camera
away from me and I  Of course, immediately
when my whole world and I
somehow saved money back then and
bought this train ticket and went there and
then I was with him during the concert
and Snoop's manager
was standing there standing there and I knew
what he looked like  Koran hatchang
and he took this camera from me
said why are you filming and I
said I'm from dabsiannen
this is a West Coast rap site well I
said that I wanted to interview Superfly
Superfly is noobman
was completely confused of course everyone is there with
noob  to talk or something and then said you
wanted to interview Superfly I said
yes said okay come here after the concert
and then we can do the
concert went there
returned my camera and um while we
were kind of walking around the room and
interviewing Superfly is it  otherwise I
ran into Noob in the hallway
and I just called what do you mean by
Snoop on the phone and
over and said
and that was what I thought,
okay, then we
did the interview with Superfly first and then
we waited there  that he was ready
we were there with two friends,
a friend from Sweden and a
friend from Switzerland, both of whom worked with me
on this website,
all of whom were much older
than me, there was the only one who
was so so young but I have  I
thought up these questions, they're up today too,
that was exactly what you
had just put out or a year later I
waited with you, thought up these questions and
then did the interview and then
just said that his cousin is
exactly the one who gave me Gazi
introduced it back then a few years ago, which
is now um from this site
told about each other and he thought
it was cool that we were focusing
and that was our first interview and
he gave me his number and we
just kept in touch after that.
I kept in touch  I
regularly did a two-hour interview
with him when I borrowed him,
he invited me to the studio and,
funnily enough, Pascal Kurusha, who worked with the
187 young,
yes Pascal Grusel is also a great photographer,
much more than a photographer, manager, video
count, whatever, I'm basically with him too
grew up and
was a hip hop nerd like me,
I actually had a few
years older than me and when I
was 15 or something like that he
gave me an ID card because he
was already 18 and one  Club and
I didn't
give back the ID and from when I was 15 until
I was 21 in America
I used this ID
we don't look alike at all
but it always worked
and I used his ID for years
at some point I got in
told this story but in any case
we didn't see each other in it. In
2007 when I went to the studio
to do an interview, Snoop said a lay
and Snoop said I think your homie
is here on the couch and I said
hey and I'm looking and Pascal  lying there
and sleeping,
I was completely amazed that I happened to see
Pascal again here at Snoop Dog in the studio in LA.
Then at some point we were
friends, of course, through the
website, we did interviews, then we
recognized Gasi as well when I
went over  and he needed my visa,
he said he makes the
letter of recommendation you get a
letter of recommendation for the US Embassy for my One visa at that time writing except I don't know but I
have this letter of recommendation
in any case it was the One why do I
have to get a visa for because Empire was a young one at the time
Company you can't
apply for this now you have to
at least somehow have so and so many
employees have so and so much turnover
in order to be able to hire foreigners as a company to
do these l2nb meadows at all, that's why the
only way for me in America was a
visa back then  To get this
all-one visa was especially for the
visa for aliens is extra
entertainment and that's just for
artists models whatever everything that yes
oh no um I have to get this video
and of course
I write a film of us  I learned from Snoop
Dogg from Ice Cube and from viewers
back then
and
then when Empire started
relatively early with our distribution style
that people signed where he
recognized artists who were distributed through us and
then
simplified artists and all sorts of things there are  basic distribution deals there are
complete label deals with
advances and budgets for several albums,
we now do more label deals
at the beginning which is more like distribution but
everything in between is just the music
product
concerts live concerts is a
partnership
so for for movies TV video games  and
something like that we have merch we have a
large music studio with me to six
studios and creative space in San
Francisco we have studies we have a
studio in New York
so as far as that is concerned full service music
company the only thing we
are not involved in at the moment is it  is
live concerts but that's a completely
different thing
for us because we have
financed tours in which we are
involved but we do
n't have a separate
department for our once really
successful artist or
what does he do in the year in terms of magnitude so
not like that  but it should be in
the order of
millions a year a few million more
so we're talking about ten from the
year
that's that's hard I think
to say yes is
percent of it for your work more
precise artist who makes the
500,000 then takes the women's percent and
if so  then someone goes through the roof
then it happens when someone
earns 500,000 but you spent 10 million,
no different than if
they earn 500,000 and you spent 50,000
somehow always 3% 10% 20%
is between 10 and 20% and so label
partnerships  are joint ventures
fifty fifty which are mostly okay, the music
rights belong to them but that was one
thing that was very important to us,
a chip remains with the artist, we
have the exclusive license to release the music,
which means the artist
keeps it without a chip and that  was one of the
reasons why many many
came because at major you basically
handed over your rights and what
are you good at so when you say
the solution is it's marketing
somehow I think for us it was one of the
things where it made us different  has is
to understand the culture we have
we can understand the how you
approach music how you approach the artist speech and and
the the the
culture company let's say it's
about when you release a street rapper now
is different than when you release a
backpack rapper somehow  from New York
as if you were a beats
artist from Nigeria, hiring people
who might understand them correctly when we
got into Nigeria and then we
hired people from the scene in
Nigeria, we don't send anyone
from America and still from you so
a good environment  I understand that but
he is also waiting for some kind of
help or or so from natural
our sales we have direct direct
with all streaming services we make
vinyl CDs cassettes we do digital
marketing we have my house everything from
social media marketing to digital
advertising campaigns  So you can
really make your promise big through
your reach or through your
communication options through my
marketing and through your proximity to
all the discussion platforms. Yes,
you can now sing the revelationships with the
streaming services playlist, buy a
tutorial
outdoor marketing
billboard, so everything can be done
for every artist  also be different and
who has made the most economic progress for you so far,
so where was that? Okay, awesome,
that was now easy for them as
I said. xxxtentacion is
one of the ten most streamed
artists globally,
has died, it was discovered four years ago, so
to speak  and then it's
okay, yes,
you can Google all night long, so
to this day he is one of the most streamed artists
in the whole world,
but if someone now has 100 million
plus sales, then there will be
a lot left over, it's
already somehow
If you've made it this far, you can actually
earn a lot of money in the end. Do
n't complain, so
yes, you have to
make a big exit with the tech sector,
build a big company and
have a comparable journey, yes, we don't have
that  a big we have we have the we
will have the sun exits
situation where somehow a lot
comes at once that's all they say
slowly built up step by step but we are
still investing most of it back
into the company and continue to build it up again as
it is now  Gasi still really wants
to live somewhere in heaven somehow and
somehow everyone else no, I
was born into fighting and it's about
me playing with the absolute
heavyweights,
how do you get such an artistic one?
It's
okay about relationships, but
then I don't think that's what you're
saying, okay, now I have to
play a part here too and somehow I
'm there, that's where I am, that has
n't changed for me, so I'm
still very, very  I love regular,
maybe you fly business class
instead of we can't get tired
when you arrive somewhere else
not someone who somehow
buys 1000 jewels but somehow
the meat or something like that never
really interested me,
I don't like it, I don't buy
bottles in the club and there's always a
little bit of
New York or something like that somewhere in the club,
but then we  If you
buy two bottles in popular clubs on Saturday evening,
people can easily
spend $10,000, so for me it still doesn't
matter how much I have or don't have
a few days at
Rock Nation in New York and was totally
amazed at
how professional they were in the whole area,
such as brand partnerships and so on, this
whole
monetization of artists who
say they also just loose assets to so that's
and there are guys in
suits and  Tie and negotiate
about their assets and present it in this way.
In my opinion, there is
no such thing in Germany that artists can
partner with brands in this way,
of course it doesn't exist in the
dimension and not in the diversity because
it also exists in the whole world
Somehow they have a catchment area for
their artists and also have big
artists
who said they even do something like that,
so it's also doing something, that
's something that we've really started to build up in the last
maybe two years or so,
we have
that  The department has been expanded in the last two
years and what
we are now focusing more and more on
because we have the right
partnerships to build long-term
partnerships with big brands,
be it a Red Bull
or any alcohol brands or
anyone we know, okay, they
have one  Budget of
because tens of thousands for the quarter
what they offer to us and
we can then
distribute it and
build it up properly but we have made a lot of
progress there but I think there
is an area where we
will continue to grow okay but for  Artist
is somehow I wouldn't have considered it that
big, but next to live it's
probably the second largest
area now. I mean, we
had, for example, artists
who it was just that wasn't sink
for a trailer for a video game and
that was somehow  for almost $300,000 for
a trailer that was somehow spent
on 30 seconds of a song,
so if you land the right things
there can definitely be
partnerships, yes
definitely in Africa, it's also a
big Africa, they have a lot of
partnerships like that  like we all the
big artists are somehow again
Samsung or Hennessy or some
brands that
get in there for the year and then you just have to
be there or just a partner for the year
or something like that, okay and the topic in general
Empire you do that now but until the
Retirement, so to speak, so
my plan was always later, when I
have a long gray beard, I want to
go back to university and I want to
be a therapist, I don't want to be old in the
music industry, I think I'll
always be 30 and
I think I'll give myself maybe
20 more  Years and then maybe mid 50's
hopefully by then I'll be in good enough
shape that I can afford
to go back to university by then
my children will be I don't have any children yet
but by then hopefully children will be the
slow university age come and um then
I would like to
have a second career
Queen therapist will
have a practice based on home and
make my own schedule and get that old
okay so around 50 you can
make music do you think and then it's
over yes I mean nothing to mine
can also last much longer than that
Making music but I wouldn't like to
somehow 70 at 70 still somehow at
festivals somehow with the 18 year olds
Roman so yes so yes my work has
a strong overlap with the
free time other means concerts parties
festivals and that was the one for people
always after  a lot of fun and it
's also but are you doing it to
scout people or to
accompany your existing artists or
both and for fun I mean of
course I have no idea
about the big festival like
Coachella or any of those things as a
man  I was still listening to music, I
was a ghost, why did you have
my favorite festival, Burning Man?
I still can't
get it, but Coachella is, I think,
especially where I like to go for
hip hop, Miami, this new thing, something
that I've already
seen from Katja  was built
yes I like to go to myself I like to go
to concerts who is
currently your
biggest caution we have an
artist designed last year who is called
black audity BLK um everything she um he
is super talented now
and I think he will be one  great
career-free American
it's like the zombie direction found
an artist we work with who
was our most designed rapper Rex life
Rush who sent me this on Instagram and
said take a look at it
and he had maybe 200 followers
or something and sometimes  you hear something that
sounds so special that you
just start very, very early
these days it's difficult nobody can
predict what will work what won't
work the thing music will
anyway and you can't do it
so foreseeably tiktok and stuff like that
I think the water is the most easy  what is the
quickest way to make a song big but
tektar doesn't make songs big. Artists
like that can shoot gold
in a 15 second clip of the song within a week
and somehow it can
make hundreds of thousands of dollars and
the artist gets a gold
record but then
no one knows  Who is that and how does
a story make up the people? There is so much
music, so much above-average good
music, there
is little
outstanding music,
of course there is every now and then there is so much
above-average because it is so easy
to make music now you can
your phone with the right
plugins and software you can
produce the whole song and put it out there
and have it all straight on Spotify from
your iPhone if you want and there are
so many talented people
making music it's
difficult to even know what
's going to work now  It's
more about what is what is the story of the
artist are they are the kids the
people are interested in lost they are they are the ones
who say to the person
because just hearing the song on a playlist
is also good and then you can
too  have a career of but if
you want to be someone who
wants to do big tours for years and something like that
or you need to be in the right
dangers of people who are interested in you
and who does it really
well so who had the best
storytelling in hip hop or  I mean, I
mean,
if you look at it now on global,
you have the DJ season, the
Snoop dogs and the really big ones, definitely
DJ Coles Kendrick people, the Drake
is a Drake, I think Drake is the one of the
RAM most impressive consistently
Drake
came out somehow in 2008 or 9 and has been at the top ever since. There
's a genius in there to
somehow grab hold of the rhythm of the culture at that moment and
join in. He's not a novator in that
sense  Rather, he is the one who
knows exactly what is happening now and where and when
he should join which trend. The
interview was seen as a beggar and
with this new podcast,
for example, that's something
that people who maybe do
n't necessarily like his music either  So listen to each other
and find it somehow funny
or something like that, it's very, very good,
it's not like that,
but we must have taken it down via YouTube,
exactly a very unusual new podcast
in it, the USA and now suddenly really
big names and with Dragon pictures, no,
yes  So
Drake is very good at always being in the
conversation about what's
happening or going on at the moment or something like that. There
are few artists, but Drake is
just someone who comes out with something new every year,
so Kendrick can disappear for three years and
comes back  and everyone listens
because he then captivated the whole generation
with his
music but it's it's it's
definitely difficult these days so
privately
already met or something but Jay Z at
the Rock Nation brunch talked briefly twice
or  something like that,
okay, well, you'll do that for another 20 years
and then
therapists will see what it
looks like for 20 years, but that was always my
ulterior motive because I was always
the listener, I used to be the one who does
n't know, I have a lot of empathy, I
like to put myself in the shoes  the skin of others
I think that's what allows me
to lead large teams because I think
I have a talent for it
[Music]
is another people suffering and
seeing things from their perspective
and understanding how I approach it
instead of there
somehow just seeing my own point of view
I've never
had an interview myself but I've
hired Polish people and I
think I have a pretty good
feel for people but one day
somehow
[music]
okay,
I forgot something else to
ask you  Is there going to be an Empire
Netflix documentary about you or something like that?
Not yet maybe it'll take a
while. The story is still in the middle
because I think they said that with
global music. I think it'll be
quite interesting. I mean, we're
in America  Moment a regional
Mexican music is exploding you
have the biggest artist is streaming
could be in the world with Drake is now Bad
Bunny only as an African artist is
Nigeria who sold 20,000 tickets in London and New York
and sold out arenas
you haven't had anything like that before like
that and me  I think that's going to make
it even more interesting and we're in
the middle of it and I'm looking forward to
seeing what else the international music scene
brings with it okay yes
so what a story from Hamburg
is cool
years a two years ago we want that
when you have  you graduated in
2006 or something like that, okay, I was, that was in
2010 and when I was there and you know, the
university wants to tell you about the cool aluminum people
who did something cool
and the name always
stood out: Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, and Philipp
I mean, I mean, if it was up to that,
we'll all
end up at Gronau or something like that,
you have to say it's
clearly cool,
crazy, what you're doing, the trip there, um,
I'm from the USA, rejecting
on the way and then you can
assess it differently  Great, thank you so much,
I'm newly engaged and
hopefully have a family in the next
year or two, so I have no
problem, which is,
well, I can imagine that I'll
often commute to New York to London,
but I've been in London since the second main sentence
I think I'll be commuting back and forth a lot
between San Francisco and London.
I really like London,
but I think as long as it lasts
everything collapses then we can go
to Germany. I always say it's
better to carry something in Germany than
to write in America
if you're financially concerned  good enough is possible in
America but if you can't afford to
send them to the right schools to live well and I think
if you have enough money you can
live very well in America but middle class
and down is a lot better in Germany there is
always here
It's still middle class over there, especially in
California, it's
difficult so it's hate or in
any case
everything if it's so open now it's so
clear so I mean you, I'm
maybe exaggerating a little bit but
I think it's definitely going
in that direction  even and um I've been studying for
as long as I'm well then in
America but when I
look at public schools for example when I look at
the publication when I
look at it that I somehow studied in the
new Hamburg for a
semester or something like 300 €  and then you
want to go to a decent university over there then you somehow pay 150,000
a year so you get out of a lot of
debt that's just a completely
different
world so let's see it's all clear
ciao ciao
[music]